what do organized crime borders and
fifty billion euros a year have in
common the answer might surprise you it
is v18
value-added tax to be more precise it's
the fraud on vit that is due when goods
crossed borders in the EU this road
amounts to fifty billion euros a year
and funds criminal networks probably
including terrorist this fifty billion
euros gets stolen from the Member States
Treasuries while they could be used to
boost our economic growth to build
schools to build hospitals to invest in
our small and medium-sized enterprises
such massive fraud exploits and
loopholes in the current vit system
today when you buy goods in your own
country you pay via tea but when goods
are sold across borders from one country
to another the sale is exempt from via
tea
this difference is legal but it makes
fraud very easy a dishonest company can
buy goods in an other EU country without
via tea and sell them legally with via
tea in its own country the company then
pockets the cash from the sale without
paying it back to its own tax
administration and very often these are
companies disappear without even being
audited this happens over and over the
same Goods can be passed back and forth
across borders between the same shady
companies and each time Fosters steal
the via T this is what we call carousel
from the European Commission today as
the simple message
let's stop this fraud urgent reform is
needed your tax money shouldn't be used
to line the pockets of criminal
and fosters reform who will help cut a
cross-border VD fraud by 80% and get
money back to the member states covers
together let's put an end to V 84
[Music]